your
invest you had the mixtape series
investments which i thought was a dope
like
yeah i feel like when people watch you
on social media they get a different
message and vibe from when they watch
most of these young artists in the game
because i feel like you know a lot of
type of these new cats is like
it's a lot of antics on the gram like i
feel like your [ __ ] can be inspirational
for a lot of people
yeah um but investments i know you
you know you're smart with your bread
you learn like like
what are you doing during the pandemic
and just
in general with your money that you
don't think the average
rapper in your position is doing uh
through the whole pandemic i've been
building my house like i got a state
that i just built so
uh you know that's what i've been pretty
much and you got a baby on the way right
yeah yeah yeah uh huh uh she she's
economy told me
uh she probably be going to label like
in the next couple days though so i
gotta you gotta get him i'm gonna shoot
yeah
are you still in alabama no no i live in
mississippi now
yeah alexi oh yeah i heard that the
taxes there are fire like you don't got
to pay state taxes or something
oh no i ain't no i no i heard that
like in texas you don't got to pay
stability
nah it's great if you could live bro in
la if you had a house here you lived
here you'd be paying [ __ ] thirty
percent
yeah yeah well that brother let me in
your [ __ ] pockets out here
not but um but like are you like
investing in any sort of like outside of
your own house like
any other stuff like oh yeah i got i
mean i got a food truck
uh i got a restaurant you know what i'm
saying uh
so that that picture of you sitting on
the top of a restaurant that's your
actual restaurant yeah
so your restaurant's called young blues
no no it's called that was before the
rest of the sign came okay
it's a mixtape cover guys yeah young
blue soul food seafood version
no it's really called gwen's house young
blues soulful
you got a food truck the restaurant what
else um
you know i do you know what i'm saying i
do it's just a lot a lot of different
screens i got a lot of different screens
of income
but i got a 12 bucks that i run out uh
when i'm not
on it you know what i'm saying so you
got a tour bus you ran out
you're in the food truck space you got
the restaurant yeah
are you um first of all salute
yes so most artists are like yo let me
go get a maybach
here's all of my advance oh god i got i
got that out the way when i was
when i was young before i even signed a
deal getting money from shows
like you got you got the dumb [ __ ] out
the way yeah i got that i was glad i got
that afterwards yeah yeah yeah cause
otherwise you you know you're you're
like
leveraging your shift yeah in a bad way
but no so um
what about like have you tapped in with
like the stock market at all or any like
the crypto [ __ ] or
uh i've been i've been testing it out
like a little bit here a little bit
they're just trying to
get a feel for it but there's just so
much stuff going on with
the scamming and stuff like oh my god
it's like i'd be scared when they
calling me a bus
i'd be like any time someone hits you
and says hey can you use an extra 10
grand
right now say no yeah because they're
just scamming the [ __ ]
i don't really think i'm too much into
this stock market right now it's too
much of
yeah it's too much [ __ ] nah you don't
like to gamble no i don't like the
camera
i respect that you got to keep your
money what is the hardest thing you've
learned about being in the restaurant
business because i know it's a really
hard business to like
succeed in we always see restaurants
coming and going all the time yeah we
[ __ ] yeah we shut down right now because
of this cover stuff so we're gonna get
ready to
come back up i'm gonna get ready to turn
into a club or hookah lounge but
uh the best thing i learned for real is
just that it's just
i ain't never really make no money from
my restaurant you know what i'm saying
like i
it was just open just for me like it was
i mean it was
it was lit it was like we made a lot of
money but it was so much overhead that
you really see a lot of money so you
like you ain't ain't no going into the
account oh i'm gonna take the ten
thousand and go do this you know what i
was thinking
probably like if you touch that like you
might not be able to pay the bills next
month yeah you're feeling
even though they had a little cause you
know i'm an artist so i
a lot of times i just come out of my
pocket but when i started coming out of
my pocket i was like no
you know first i was just breaking even
oh i'm probably making a little money
you know what i'm saying probably that's
a thousand or two you know what i'm
saying but i was satisfied with that
because i was like
at least
i just wanted to have a restaurant like
just something in my city you know
saying he didn't matter if i was
just breaking even because i really
really doing it for the profit
yeah so uh but yeah once i started to
come out of my pocket you know what i
said then we was only in business like
three months before the cover hit we was
doing good for the curve hit
so we was real fragile you know what i'm
saying so oh yeah that was just the
worst time people started catching cold
with them up and uh like auto
workers stuff just this is this is in
this is in mobile
yeah yeah yeah yeah so i had yeah i had
i had to shut it down and then once i
shut it down people's
about new jobs and just a whole lot of
stuff so i i'm just remodeling it right
now
yeah i feel like i've heard though that
alabama uh being the
crazy right-wing redneck state that it
is most people
don't even act like the kovich is real
down there my boy was down there for
labor day and he was like nobody's
wearing masks
they definitely like you know they they
they weird down there but i had this
thing called blue bass that i was
throwing down
i had everybody on it like you know
saying uh
42 dogs free birthday yeah yeah no it
was for my album release part
uh but it was like you just did was that
recently uh yeah but i did i ended up
doing a little show because they council
it was supposed to be at last people
stayed in my head like 20 artists pnb
rock
right i had everybody in the game they
really black youngster
lucha everybody they mess with me for
real they can't figure it out
yeah but they came back and started
throwing football games at the same
place and i'm like
so that was like a big thing with the
news and stuff they was trying to get me
to get political and stuff like that but
i really wanted too much do it right
then because i know i don't want to
throw it again and i want to throw it
you know what i'm saying i ain't really
want to stir up i know i could have
stirred it up you don't want to stir it
up because it might [ __ ] up like next
year if you want to do it at the same
place yeah
yeah i i feel like i was just going to
lift them heavy because
the covert you know saying the cover
stuff you know it's probably
would have been hard for me to win
against it